growing up in a small Virginia Town near
the mountains right on the border of
West Virginia Zane heard all kinds of
stories from his grandmother Tales of
mountain lions who could transform into
ghostly women the talipow a fluffy
rodent-like creature on an endless quest
to get its tail back from the hunter who
took it the Mothman that appeared with
glowing red eyes to warn of impending
tragedy most of all she warned him about
the deer sometimes she used to say when
you're out in the woods late at night
you'll see a deer acting a little bit
funny maybe it's making strange sounds
maybe it's standing up like a man maybe
it's staring at you from the shadows and
won't look away if you ever see one of
these deer promise me you'll get away
from it as fast as possible don't look
at it don't talk to it just get far far
away he promised her every time but as
he got older he started to forget his
grandma's stories letting them fade away
with memories of the Easter Bunny and
Santa Claus he didn't think about the
stories again until he was older a
junior in college and embarking on a
camping trip with his roommate Josh they
were both staying with Zayn's family for
the summer and had been enjoying the
sunshine and fresh air they'd gone
hiking picked blackberries and gone
fishing to their hearts content after a
while they got sick of sleeping in the
cramped house and decided to have a
proper camping trip out in the mountains
campsites were crowded this time of year
but Zane knew a spot just isolated
enough that they could kick back enjoy
nature and relax in peace they packed
their supplies and headed out into the
forest for a weekend they would never
forget by Nightfall Zane and Josh had
pitched their tents built a fire and
were starting to make some dinner they
roasted hot dogs and heated cans of
beans over the fire and decided to start
telling some classic scary stories
sitting by the crackling fire listening
to the rustling leaves snapping twigs
and the chittering of animals all around
Zayn couldn't help but remember remember
the stories he had almost forgotten all
the strange inexplicable things that
came out after the sun went down and the
forest went quiet he thought he could
hear the footsteps of something walking
by their campsite circling them but it
was probably just his imagination as
Josh told stories about babysitters
stalked by Killers and drivers picking
up ghostly hitchhikers Zane was thinking
about the deer he shuddered but shook it
off and after some more stories and a
few too many s'mores the two friends
decided to get some sleep after several
hours Zane woke to the sound of Josh
unzipping his tent he sat up ready to
yell at his friend for waking him up but
the sight of Josh's pale frightened face
stopped him there's something here was
all Josh could say his hands Zane
noticed were shaking hey man it's so
it's okay let's check it out Zane patted
Josh on the shoulder he was pretty sure
his friend just wasn't used to camping
in actual nature but reach for his
hunting knife Justin
he grabbed a flashlight and switched it
on following Josh out into the darkness
he swept the beam across the clearing
and it illuminated a pair of orange eyes
staring directly at him from behind a
nearby tree what the he approached the
shape trying to get a clear look at it
as it became more illuminated his
stomach dropped it was a deer but
something was wrong with it its mouth
was wide open its jaw working up and
down like it was trying to make a sound
but nothing came out but that wasn't the
worst part as the flashlight beam
illuminated the animal's body Zane
realized that somehow its head was on
backwards what the Josh appeared behind
him gasping shh Zayn shushed him
intensely he suddenly remembered his
grandmother's warnings you know what I
don't feel so great I think we should go
back to the car and head to my place he
gave Josh a look shaking his head as if
to say don't say another word by the
glow of their flashlights the two packed
up their campsite all under the Gaze of
the misshapen deer they drove home in
silence Josh only speaking once to ask
what was that thing Zayn shook his head
I don't know but it wasn't a deer they
crept back into the house and went to
bed they knew they would never speak of
tonight ever again as Zane began to
Drift Off to Sleep his last conscious
thought was to glance out the window
there in the yard not five feet away was
a deer watching he didn't know it but
that night Zane encountered an instance
of
scp-6448
scp-6448 is an anomalous species of
creatures that appear to belong to the
server Day family nicknamed the not deer
they are highly Intel and can be
distinguished from ordinary deer by
unusual behavior and physical
deformities some of these have included
legs that bend backwards the eyes of an
animal other than deer forward-facing
eyes jerking movements lack of fear
towards humans and walking on two hind
legs most notably and most frightening
scp-6448 instances will watch and stalk
humans for a duration of hours or even
days they will follow humans home and
steal items from their domains including
weapons food and other personal items
they're most frequently found in the
Deep Woods at night when a person is
completely alone if someone encounters
an instance of
scp-6448 if they acknowledge any of the
creature's anomalous traits it will
attack in order to limit the loss of
life and ensure that the SCP Foundation
employs exercise the utmost caution when
dealing with
scp-6448 the cryptozoology division
issued the following guidelines if you
notice a deer that seems off look away
and ignore it if it knows that you've
noticed it it's too late if you hear
your name whistling or something else in
the woods calling for you don't
acknowledge it never acknowledge it
exists don't respond don't go looking
for it don't call back to it if you're
walking at night and you feel something
breathing on your neck or Whispering
behind you the key to your safety is
pretending that everything is normal
your survival is dependent on your
ignorance whatever
scp-6448 is they appear to be
intelligent enough to understand when
they are being studied and they don't
seem to like it very much on January 11
1994 a group of three
scp-6448 instances broke into site 41 in
North Carolina using a tunnel they had
carved over a long period of time at the
time there was an instant in containment
but in all of the chaos of the breach
the specimen was lost every time an
instance was captured and contained near
scp-6448's habitat we would later Escape
via similar tunnels
scp-6448 was officially classified by
the SCP Foundation in 1980 but those
from the Appalachian region have known
about these strange creatures since at
least
1947. from folk tales and campfire
stories to Second Hand and even
firsthand encounters the locals are
aware of the not deer's existence and
are largely familiar with the
precautions necessary to avoid them
though many of the civilians that
encounter
scp-6448 avoid notifying the authorities
there have been several recorded 9-1-1
calls involving the not deer since 2000.
the following is a log of those calls
February 1st 2000 victim age 41 female
dialed Emergency Services after hearing
their name being called from the woods
near their home the victim recounts the
vocalization being likened to a scream
and a voice that they do not recognize
and requested assistance in locating the
source emergency Personnel requested the
subject Place their phone on the floor
outside the home to listen for the
alleged sounds after two minutes a
vocalization was heard that was calling
to the subject by name emanating from
the nearby Forest the subject was
instructed to investigate the
disturbance themselves and keep Services
updated on the situation the victim then
began to walk into the Woodland getting
about 50 meters into the underbrush
before inexplicably stopping they claim
there to be a noticeably large deer
standing in the way of the path she
begins to walk closer though States it
does not move subject diverts From the
Path and begins walking in a different
direction after 30 minutes no source of
the voice is determined the caller
returns to the residence June 13 2002
victim aged 28 male calls 9-1-1
regarding a home break-in the caller
notes numerous items to be missing from
their residence and requests and
investigation operators dispatched two
investigators to visit the home and and
pertain a potential perpetrator the pair
note that based on earlier CCTV images
all Cutlery sharp objects Firearms light
bulbs and a single copy of the novel The
Day After Roswell are missing also noted
is that there is a complete lack of any
fingerprints at the scene with no doors
or Windows having been broken into
analysis of the home CCTV footage
revealed there to be a two-hour period
of missing film with the exception of a
single frame containing a service Nippon
on its hind legs reaching towards the
camera its frontal Hooves have been
warped to resemble fingers no footage of
the entity exiting the home was
discovered November 19 2005 a cattle
farmer age 54 male reported to local
authorities the sudden disappearance of
over 30 percent of his largest herd
response teams surged the nearby area
for four hours though found no trace of
his cattle the victim was recommended to
set up trail cameras and note any
unusual activity overnight at 1 11 am
two
scp-6448 are seen walking through the
field before fleeing one places an
object into the ground later discovered
to be a single Fork a week after this
discovery 200 discarded bovine Hooves
appear at the location March 4th 2009
victim age unknown gender unknown dials
9-1-1 to request assistance from Animal
Services the victim is standing within a
forest in front of a service elephus
which is violently contorting the victim
attempts to State you better get a vet
or something I don't think it's well
before piercing Screech is heard and the
line Falls silent recovered footage
depicts the aforementioned animal
squirming seemingly in pain a vicious
churning is audible as a black mass
erupts out to the instance and the video
turns to static October 11 2012 victim
age 23 male is a junior Wildlife officer
at the Cherokee National Forest
Tennessee they radio their supervisor in
the early morning regarding a herd of
odacolius virginius within the reserve
supposedly there is a single animal that
upon first glance appears average though
possesses Divergent attributes including
backwards joints enlarged abdomen and
forward-facing Eyes Upon stating this a
distant whistle is audible the victim
stumbles slightly they begin to say what
the did it just whistle at me before the
sound of hooves rapidly getting closer
is heard notably the hoof steps did not
sound to be in the traditional Gallop of
a servid October 12 2012 the former
victim supervisor calls authorities
following the victim's absence from The
Reserve Night Shift following this their
radio begins to crackle the victim's
voice can be heard on the other end
Eddie requests these supervisor's
attention he calls regarding a herd of
autokolius virginius within the reserve
they claim there is a single animal that
upon first glance appears average though
possesses Divergent attributes including
backwards joints enlarged abdomen and
forward-facing eyes suspecting the
creature to be a rare genetic
malformation the victim requests their
supervisor to come to the location the
supervisor questions the victim about
what happened the night previous there
is no reply upon the supervisors and law
enforcement's arrival at the site a herd
of approximately 80 oticolios virginius
was present a single entity is in the
field Center and appears to be standing
separate from the rest of the group it
flees the scene upon realizing the law
enforcement's presence where it formally
stood lay a standard two-way radio April
8 2016. victim age 35 female dials 9-1-1
using a satellite phone distressed they
State they are in reductive County Woods
and are being followed she claims that
despite seeing no one for the duration
of her hike she quote feels as if she's
being watched and has heard someone
walking behind her at various points in
the trip the victim is unable to give an
adequate description of their location
but knows the route to return to her
residence operators request the victim
to return to a point wherein she can
provide a sufficient Geographic
description of her position the victim
remains on the line for the duration of
the hike back to a readily used portion
of the Wilderness Trail along the
journey various unnatural sounds can be
heard these include footsteps Rock
slides coughing whispering and whistling
nearing the main trail all Woodland
noises such as birds and winds see
suddenly and the victims State she can
see a malformed deer carcass coated in a
thick layer of black slime at this time
human screams can be heard in the
distance operators request the victim
continue and ignore the other stimuli
agents embedded in local law enforcement
suspecting as C p6448 involved notify
gamma 4 to the situation 20 minutes
later the victim returns to the main
trail gamma 4 now operating the 9-1-1
call informs the victim not to respond
to any further unusual activity and
greatly outlines service protocol for
the duration of the victim's journey to
her home two sets of breathing are
audible the victim successfully returns
to a residence and shuts the door behind
her now out of sight from
scp-6448 Agents inquire of the victim's
address and the victim promptly complies
operatives instruct the victim to have
possession of all firearms and weapons
on the premises and to barricade herself
inside a safe space with one exit point
the victim swiftly begins grabbing all
available weapons and throwing them
inside a wardrobe it is at this time
there's a knock on the front door the
victim does not respond and continues to
hoard sharp objects from kitchen drawers
the knocking becomes more violent as the
handle is jostled and is shaken
incessantly a voice on the other side it
repeats the phrase hello it is me hello
let me in in a calm manner as the door
begins to shake the victim retreats to
her wardrobe armed with a small firearm
upon sealing herself in the space the
knocking ceases and footsteps can be
heard becoming further away the sound of
Galloping is audible as the front door
caves in hoof steps can now be heard
inside the home The Entity continues to
repeat hello it is me hello let me in as
it searches the small building a bright
light flashes overhead seemingly
circling the house eventually The Entity
enters the victim's bedroom through a
small slit in the wardrobe door the
victim can see a service canadensis
standing on its hind legs and surveying
the room its movements are crooked and
stiff seeming to struggle to stand in a
bipedal fashion it slouches down to a
quadrupedal Crouch similar to The Stance
of an arachnid it inhales heavily and
its head locks on The View of the
Wardrobe it is noted as possessing human
eyes it scampers towards the subject and
opens the door a single gunshot is heard
responders found no trace of either
scp-6448 or the victim containment of
scp-6448 is focused on the investigation
of any deer exhibiting anomalous trades
in and around the Appalachian area any
civilian sightings of
scp-6448 are to be handled by mobile
task force gamma 4 or the green Stags
any possible deaths resulting from
scp-6448 will be blamed on hiking
accidents and any reported sightings can
be explained away with chronic wasting
disease CWD occasionally referred to as
zombie deer disease is a prion disease
affecting members of the cervedae family
symptoms of the illness include loss of
motor function control and damage to
decision making as well as gradual
degradation of all mental faculties it
is 100 fatal however though the disease
does exist most recorded cases of it in
the Appalachian region can actually be
attributed to instances of
scp-6448 any captured instances of
scp-6448 should be transported to
site-44 for the cryptozoology division's
containment and study on November 29
2019 they finally got their chance to
bring a not deer into custody the green
Stags were able to capture an instance
of
scp-6448 with a help from MTF new 7
hammer down and their heavy Vehicles
Division as well as some experimental
shock rifles one not deer was knocked
unconscious in the conflict and its body
was loaded onto an armored helicopter
and flown straight to site-44 in Essex
England at the site it was then placed
in a reinforced steel containment cell
and heavily sedated this entire process
went off without a hitch as the entity
began to regain Consciousness
cryptozoology specialist F Oz watched it
through a one-way glass window and
attempted to speak to it through the
intercom greetings
scp-6448 researcher Oz began at the
sound of his voice the creature jumped
to its feet staring at the intercom can
you understand me we've seen your genus
speak English just fine in the past the
animal did not answer but began licking
one of its legs and behaving as if it
were an ordinary deer researcher on his
side impatiently please we know your
secret the knocked deer stopped what it
was doing freezing completely still as
it listened to the words admittedly it
wasn't exactly well kept if you just
look at yourself for more than a few
seconds it is very clear that you're not
normal at this the creature which had
been facing away from the window
swiveled its neck 180 degrees breaking
its own spine with an audible crack it
stared unblinking at the window and
directly at researcher Oz Oz turned to
the containment staff suddenly anxious I
thought you said this was one way the
staff assured him that it was and there
was no way the not deer could see him
still its eyes were locked directly on
his face he shook off the sense of
unease and continued his line of
questioning are you something imitating
dear it is clear that if so you possess
basic anatomical knowledge of them
though details are clearly faulty in
fact a better question would be how if
in fact you are not what you pretend to
be the not deer opened its mouth at this
revealing unusually sharp teeth it moved
its jaws if attempting to speak but only
a choking sound came out
shall we move on Oz asked but I'm more
concerned with here is why you take on
people is it a vendetta spiked food for
the first time in the interview the not
deer blinked it was an unnatural
movement forced and deliberate like the
creature was attempting to engage in an
ordinary Behavior rather than actually
experiencing an involuntary impulse
responding is mandatory researcher Oz
prompted the creature did not react if
you will not comply maz's tone grew
Stern frustrated maybe you'd like to see
your brand new containment cell at last
The Entity spoke dreams
Church its voice resembled the distorted
version of Oz's research what kind of Oz
wasn't able to finish his question July
7
1947 the creature said before ramming
into the one-way glass and cracking it
azaz stumbled backwards from the force
the creature collapsed on the ground
seizing and screaming as its abdomen get
the Stags in here now Oz cried out but
it was too late the black mass of
something shiny and tendered leaped out
of the not deer scuttling around the
cell before shattering the window and
leaving the empty shell of a deer behind
the site-44 breach system activated and
attempted to initiate emergency
containment protocols but the mysterious
black mass escaped its sector made its
way toward the main exit broke through
the glass of the front exit door and
vanished into the Shrubbery outside the
escaped anomaly could not be found and
recontained ever since this incident
there have been a record-breaking number
of chronic wasting disease cases
identified in Deer here in the
surrounding area as well as an
unprecedented increase in UFO reports
further research is currently ongoing
but it is unknown whether we will ever
truly know what these creatures are only
one thing is for certain they are
definitely not dear now go check out
scp-968 sleep killer and scp-2571
cracklewood park for more anomalies that
I'm sure you'll never want to sleep
again wait is that a deer behind you oh